(hip hop music)
- My ambition for the summer,
is to create like I've never created.
Yes!
To be the best partner to my partner
that I can be.
(pop)
To get dash money!
- Darling, summer is
only three months long!
- To longer summers!
(hip hop music)
I don't wanna just be known as a painter,
I want to be multidisciplinary.
Greer, in his natural habitat!
- I bet that you never that you would see
your "my name isn't" on
the side of a bus ad.
- I do not want to be more famous
for an ad than for my art.
- You're not feelin' it, huh?
- I mean...
No buildings blocking this
gorgeous heat and sun.
- Skylar needs to know
that she does not have two mommies.
(squeals)
- Nope, what'd I say about this?
(clicks)
I said stop!
- This love shit is a motherfucker.
(gentle music)
- I am the only one that
can see your real potential.
- There is nothing romantic
about being a broke artist.
(sighs)
- I'm lost.
- You're on a journey of your own!
- [Nola] Choosing.
- May I take your picture, please?
(click)
- I really got a thing for you.
- You need to take off your Jordans.
- Get back to your art, Nola.
- I got work to do.
I promise to do the best I can,
be the best I can.
With love, Nola Darling.
(off-pitch vocalizing)
Shut the fuck up!
♪ I gave you all my life ♪